will rise for him and the consistency  eric i think the biggest challenge for  him going forward  is gonna be getting the open looks  because defenses are gonna start really  marking him and trying to take away his  catches you said a magic word a moment  ago  bam we'll have more on bam and kendrick  nunn from jason jackson coming up  shortly  good news coming up with some different  combinations of players on both ends of  the floor  rough night so far shooting the ball for  tyler hero he is one  for seven so the knight could be over  for butler nine points three boards two  assists  in 11 minutes dragach 11 points  in 11 first half minutes back donovan  steps back  miss the bank comes a much more normal  2-3 zone look at the spacing right here  between the players on the bench how  unique is this with the social  distancing going on  unbelievable well sign of the times here  in the  covet 19 era everybody trying to deal  with it  of course the nba